des nouvelles disciples bloquées par
Facebook et instagram sur les comptes de
centaines de milliers Canadiens le
résultat de bras de fer entre méta et le
gouvernement fédéral entourant le projet
de loi C18
Ottawa veut forcer les géants du
numérique à rétribuer les médias quand
il publie du contenu d'information sur
leur page mais ta réplique en lançant ce
qu'elle appelle un test qui vise un à 5%
de ses abonnés bien que ces tests de
produits soient temporaires et crimeta
nous entendons mettre fin à l'accès au
contenu de nouvelles de façon permanente
suivant l'adoption du projet de loi C18
l'arrivée des Google Facebook Instagram
Youtube de ce monde a contribué à
l'érosion des revenus publicitaires des
médias traditionnels le ministre du
Patrimoine canadien invite méta à
négocier
dans cette nouvelle société où les
médias sociaux ont joué un rôle
prépondérant mais ça sera pas au
détriment de la démocratie ça je vous
garantis un point de vue partagé par le
bloc et le NPD je crains compris des
gens qui en ont grandement besoin d'un
accès à l'information qui pourrait leur
être crucial alors c'est extrêmement mal
avisé c'est important de ne pas reculer
et complètement irresponsable parce
qu'ils ont pris des milliards de dollars
du Canada ils ont presque rien donné le
président de la Fédération
professionnelle des journalistes du
Québec accusent l'état de défendre ses
intérêts financiers aux dépend du droit
à l'information c'est du terrorisme
numérique qui est fait par des super
puissances numériques qui pensent avoir
le droit de tout faire le chef
conservateur blâme Justin Trudeau je
suis contre les MNH je suis contre la
censure et je trouve que la
l'incompétence totale de Justin Trudeau
est responsable pour ça
le Canada n'est pas le seul État dans la
mer de Facebook et Instagram la
Californie qui veut aussi que metape sa
juste part pourraient être la prochaine
à subir les tests de ce géant du web ici
Valérie Michaela
Ottawa